[Music]
declining attendance at America's
churches has been a persistent trend in
recent decades but now some churches are
taking a novel approach to keeping their
doors open by renting out otherwise
empty space during the usually quiet
midweek Omar Villafranca has the story
church on Sunday looks very different
from church on Monday at White Rock
United Methodist in Dallas during the
week there's a florist filling out
orders next to an artist working on a
project and down the hall
closing up tai chi students practicing
Tai Chi Bible lessons now share a space
with businesses it's part of a growing
trend to keep churches open as
attendance falls
Larry Duggan's heads up the missional
wisdom Foundation a group that helps
congregations become a place for
commerce and what happens if some church
is closed when they can't get beyond
that unless they have some extraordinary
other way to get people to come attend
we can no longer afford to maintain a
60,000 square foot facility and senior
pastor Mitchell Boone admits White Rock
Methodist needed a miracle to stay open
well I mean we just knew that we were an
unsustainable institution we were
spending way too much money to keep the
doors open and the lights on and the
staff paid and Sunday morning going and
so it was clearly a move out of
desperation we were close to death their
prayers were answered when they opened
up their basement for business in
addition to creating a mixed workspace
for startups to rent the church reached
out to groups in need an African refugee
group that sews bags and other products
now rents a room from them more churches
across the u.s. are opening their doors
for prayer and profit oh yeah we've had
yoga we've had aerial yoga the Tai Chi
we have Tai Chi meets twice a week we
have Zen meditation on the second floor
was there any business that was awful
yes so we were approached by an
entrepreneur that that taught pole
dancing classes okay and she was
wonderful but we simply said we can't
have pole dancing in the basement of the
church if and part of that was simply
looking out on our part for the best
interest of the congregation Lila James
has been a member of this church for 44
years she says other church members
weren't fully sold on the idea of
renting out space but this daughter of a
preacher embraced it I attended the yoga
class and I remember one day we got the
giggles because we we were just enjoying
it so much and we thought well this is
well the way church should be we should
be able to have other aspects of our
lives here for CBS this morning Saturday
Omar Villafranca Dallas